gedenken in der nacht an die
verstorbenen arbeiter und feuerwehrleute
auch 35 jahre nach der atomkatastrophe
sitzt der schmerz noch immer tief
[Musik]
mindestens 30 menschen kommen direkt
nach dem unglück ums leben
die zahl der strahlen toten ist noch
immer umstritten
mehrere tausend menschen sterben in den
jahren danach an den folgen
[Musik]
meine freunde mein mann alle die minar
waren sind nicht mehr da ich werde immer
an sie denken es ist sehr hart für mich
[Musik]
wir wollen nicht dass sich solche fehler
in zukunft wiederholen
unsere kinder sollen sich an dieses
desaster erinnern und die richtigen
entscheidungen treffen
[Musik]
es sind diese bilder die sich
eingebrannt haben ins kollektive
gedächtnis
es ist der 26 april 1986 ein test in
reaktorblock 4 des atomkraftwerks
tschernobyl gerät außer kontrolle
[Musik]
um 1 uhr 23 kommt es zum gau dem größten
anzunehmenden unfall eine gigantische
explosion die radioaktive teilchen in
die luft schleudert und die umgebung
verstrahlt die führung der sowjetunion
versuchte damals zunächst das ausmaß zu
verheimlichen
bis es nicht mehr anders ging
[Musik]
suzuki das hirsche im frühjahr ihr
geweih abwerfen ist keine besonderheit
dass daran radioaktive strahlung zu
messen ist allerdings schon
das könnte vom sand kommen oder
natürlich im geweih selbst stecken
andré simon arbeitet in der sperrzone
von tschernobyl
hier untersucht der biologe wie die
tierwelt sich entwickelt 35 jahre nach
dem gau dass es hier keine eingriffe
durch den menschen gibt hat tierarten
erlaubt neu aufzutauchen oder sich
zahlenmäßig wieder zu vermehren
die auf dem übrigen gebiet der ukraine
sehr selten sind darunter luchse wölfe
elche
und vereinzelt treten auch wisente die
kommen aus belarus rüber die
reaktorexplosion verwandelte 4700
quadratkilometer erde in
lebensfeindlicher land sich selbst
überlassen entwickelt sich seit der
jahrtausendwende ein bio reservat dessen
artenvielfalt und populationsdichte
wissenschaftler erstaunen
zwei wochen pro monat verbringt andré in
der sperrzone von tschernobyl
er untersucht wie belastet die
nistplätze der vögel sind ihr gefieder
ihr coach
die strahlenbelastung des schlangenbader
codes ist zehnmal höher als die der
umgebung ein gutes zeichen meint andré
denn es zeige dass der vom aussterben
bedrohte raubvogel die radionuklide
schnell wieder ausscheiden der mit der
nahrung aufnimmt wie oft er diese stufen
hinauf gestiegen ist hat sergej parikh
was nicht gezählt kaum jemand kennt den
ort der katastrophe so gut wie er der
sicherheitsingenieur führt unser team
durch das atomkraftwerk in tschernobyl
seit der katastrophe arbeitet sergej
hier bis heute der tag der das leben von
zigtausenden menschen so veränderte und
die bilder noch immer präsent
auch 35 jahre danach
während der havarie befanden wir uns
neben dem kraftwerk und 500 600 meter
entfernt als wir die explosion hörten
waren wir auf der anderen seite
wir hatten nicht gesehen was konkret
passiert war und entsprechend dem was
man uns gelehrt hatte konnten wir nicht
glauben dass unser kraftwerk in die luft
fliegen kann
wir dachten das war vielleicht
wasserstoff oder öl
aber dann sahen wir alles mit unseren
eigenen augen dass es block 4
faktisch nicht mehr gab es heute
überspannt ein gigantischer sarkophag
aus stahl die atom ruine
die 109 meter hohe konstruktion
überdeckt seit mehr als vier jahren den
explodierten reaktor 4
und dass viele nicht wissen das
kraftwerk in tschernobyl ist bis heute
aktiv wenn auch nicht mehr als akw
sondern als stromverteilung anlage rund
2800 arbeiterinnen und arbeiter sind
hier noch im einsatz
im schichtbetrieb sicherheitsingenieur
parikh was führt unser team weiter durch
das atomkraftwerk gespenstisch und
faszinierend zugleich
[Musik]
in den kontrollräumen und blocken
scheint die zeit stehen geblieben zu
sein
[Musik]
wir befinden uns auf dem plateau von
reaktor 3 so ein gab es auch in block 4
einen identischen er befindet sich dort
hinter der wand hier ist die
strahlenbelastung akzeptabel um sich
hier für einige zeit aufzuhalten
eine schicht gut kann man hier schon
arbeiten letzten april brennen die
kontaminierten wäldern nach tschernobyl
wochenlang die flammen erreichen weder
die reaktorruine noch die atommülllager
städten und doch führen sie die gefahr
vor augen die noch immer von hier aus
geht im waldboden und den bäumen findet
sich die höchste konzentration an
radioaktiven stoffen
wenn es brennt gelangen sie zusammen mit
den nicht radioaktiven stoffen und den
aero sohlen in die luft und verteilen
sich dieser rauch ist sehr radio dadurch
den brand radionuklide in großen mengen
in die luft geraten
[Musik]
die radioaktivität stieg durch die
brände auch außerhalb der sperrzone
gesundheitsgefahr habe nicht bestanden
sagen die behörden
die mitarbeiter von eco zentren
kontrollieren die strahlenwerte
regelmäßig cäsium und strontium haben 35
jahre nach der kernschmelze
die erste halbwertszeit hinter sich
sorgen macht sergej kirow dem leiter von
egozentrik ein anderes isotop im bestand
der imitierten radionuklide der
plutonium isotope gab es das beta
strahlende plutonium 241 das eine
halbwertszeit von 14 jahren hat das
zerfällt in das alpha strahlende
americium 241
alphastrahlung gilt als gefährlicher als
beta strahlung damit ist das
zerfallsprodukt gesundheitsschädlicher
als das ursprünglich freigesetzte isotop
und die americana wird steigen bis ins
jahr 2056 berechnen die wissenschaftler
damit steigt auch das risiko für die
menschen in der region
davon wollen die etwa 100 dorfbewohner
die innerhalb der sperrzone wohnen
nichts wissen
nach dem reaktorunfall wurden sie
umgesiedelt schon neun monate später
kehrte anna button ja zurück obwohl das
illegal war
ach ich kenne hier jedes loch wie und wo
man durch schlüpfen kann
als wir wieder gekommen sind sagte man
uns dass man uns aus dem fonds vier
jahren würde aber jetzt können sie uns
doch nur noch ins grab jagen die
strahlung innerhalb der 30 kilometer
sperrzone ist unterschiedlich hoch in
bekannten hotspots kann sie tausendfach
über dem normalwert liegen
trotzdem kommen touristen aus aller welt
auch in die geisterstadt pripjat
der tourismus ist zu einer wichtigen
einnahmequelle geworden
[Musik]
tschernobyl hotspot nicht mehr nur noch
für radioaktivität sondern auch für
instagram fotos durch den betrieb des
akw es haben sich über die jahre 21.000
brennelemente angesammelt derzeit
existieren zwei zwischenlager für die
abgebrannten brennstäbe 1 soll
geschlossen werden
droht jetzt eine neue atomare gefahr
durch das zwischenlager nur des
schuldners ruck die berechnete zeit für
die verlagerung der verbrauchten
kernelemente aus dem lager 1 ins lager 2
beträgt zehn jahre
vielleicht auch etwas mehr der einfluss
auf die umwelt und die bevölkerung ist
nicht groß alles im bereich der
zulässigen werte die größte radioaktive
beeinträchtigung der umwelt geht von
radionukliden aus die sich rund um das
kraftwerk befinden und durch die havarie
von 1986
aus block 4 herausgeschleudert wurde
stück für stück wird der reaktor
demontiert tonnenweise verstrahltes
material geborgen
eine grüne wiese wie man so schön sagt
wird man hier nicht zurücklassen
es wird immer ein dunkelbrauner fleck
bleiben hier soll ein komplex zur
verarbeitung radioaktiver abfälle
entstehen
ein großer teil der radioaktivität zog
1986 ins benachbarte belarus katja
stauber anfang dreißig als reaktor 4 und
tschernobyl explodierte
23 kilometer von ihrem haus entfernt
erst acht tage später erfuhr die
belarussen davon
am vierten mai begannen mit der
evakuierung die kühe und schweine hat
man mitgenommen ganze busse sind
gekommen um die menschen an verschiedene
orte zu bringen
knapp ein viertel des gebietes von
belarus wurde durch die katastrophe von
tschernobyl schwer nuklear verseuchte
die datenlage über die heutige
strahlenbelastung ist dürftig oder unter
verschluss
falls es studien gibt werden diese nicht
publik gemacht und wir wissen nichts
darüber
man kann annehmen dass die ergebnisse
der art sind dass man uns lieber nichts
darüber sagen will oder katholisch
verzehrten holzköpfe denn belarus hat
der kernenergie keineswegs abgeschworen
in sichtweite zu litauen ist in den
letzten jahren ein neues atomkraftwerk
entstanden gebaut vom russischen
staatsunternehmen rosatom mit
finanzieller hilfe aus moskau
lasst uns applaudieren sagt der diktator
als er im november vergangenen jahres
den meiler ein weit die
sicherheitsbedenken in der europäischen
nachbarschaft sind groß schon mehrfach
musste das akw vom netz gehen die rede
ist von kleineren zwischenfällen zurück
bei nadjeschda schon fünf monate nach
der explosion von tschernobyl erklärte
sie in ihr dorf am rande der
belarussischen sperrzone zurück
hier lebt sie hauptsächlich von dem was
sie selbst anbaut 15
ach die kann man essen wenn wir keine
kartoffeln mehrheiten dann bestärken wir
ganz bestimmt die durchschnittliche
strahlendosis in deutschland liegt bei
etwa 2 millisievert pro jahr
nadia spitze erreichen diesen wert schon
noch etwas über zwei tagen
wir riechen die radioaktive strahlung
nicht sie hat auch keine farbe wir leben
hier und fertig die unsichtbare gefahr
verdrängen
auch das gehört zum erbe von tschernobyl
weit über die grenzen der sperrzone
hinaus
währenddessen tut sich unter dem
sarkophag erstaunliches auch
wissenschaftler lernen bei ihren
forschungen hier im sperrgebiet ständig
dazu bei wasserproben aus block 4
stellten forscher aus kiew und japan zb
fest dass es mikroorganismen gibt die
radioaktive elemente aufnehmen können
und verarbeiten
das ist sehr interessant denn sobald wir
die arten zugehörigkeit bestimmen können
ist es durchaus wahrscheinlich dass das
eine neue art von bakterium ist die sich
unter den bedingungen im sarkophag in
dieser zone der abschottung
herausgebildet hat das wäre ein beweis
für eine recht hohe geschwindigkeit der
evolution dieses gesicht im sakko 35
jahre nach der katastrophe wollen die
menschen rund um tschernobyl nicht nur
zurückschauen sondern den blick auch
nach vorne richten
im sperrgebiet finden mittlerweile
kunstaktionen stadt sowie diese riesige
laser animation an einer einst geheimen
radaranlage das interesse an tschernobyl
ist in den letzten jahren enorm
gewachsen und mit der strahlung sowie
der bergung und entsorgung des atommülls
von damals bleibt die atomare gefahr
hier noch für lange zeit real